hello everyone and welcome back to the
capablanca saga we finished the 1914
tournament to son Peter Berg and we've
covered some of the games from the
simultaneous exhibition that capablanca
held also in st. Peterburg
one of them being against his famous
loss against the composer Sega
Sevilla Prokofiev now we enter this game
it's capablanca versus our Lopez
Martinez maybe it's even rule opus
Martinez I don't know I was not able to
confirm this maybe you'd have better
luck figuring out who this gentleman is
but since I couldn't the hoodie guy's
back and also this was played in Buenos
Aires capablanca boarded a steamer from
from sunk Peter Berg and he went off for
a trip to Argentina where he will held
hold on either another simultaneous
exhibition against ten players and well
during his trip he kept a journal he
talked about a lot of things he
mentioned that now there was a big
tournament going on in Mannheim in
Germany but that determent was missing
five of the strongest players in the
world
I will champion Manuel ask her Blanca
Rubinstein schlechte and tight man and
Capablanca says it's due to due to the
money issues now I don't think he meant
like that the the prize fund wasn't
enough for a tournament but maybe he was
expecting like an invitation money
invitation perhaps like the one Lasker
received just for appearing in the 1914
sankt-petersburg tournament where he won
a lot well he gained a lot more money by
just appearing rather than by winning
the tournament but okay determined did
take place and Capablanca didn't mention
it a bit in his journal and he said that
he thinks in the Rubinstein not true
battalion and Spielman were the
favourites to win this tournament and
the tournament did happen but it did not
finish
due to the outbreak of the world war
they had ended the tournament but I did
prepare the standings of this tournament
there you can see my Mannheim tournament
of 1914 couple uncle was right Alexander
I did indeed win this tournament and
Rudolf Spielman who Capablanca also held
as a high favourite won third place with
me Emil and Widmer in second place but
yeah only twelve rounds were held and
then it had to finish and also due to
the outbreak of the world war
considered that Alaska's match with
Rubinstein will not take place so well
the next serious contender when the war
finishes capablanca considered himself
to be that person and he talked about
that a bit a bit more he also mentions I
I included it in the quote above the
board say that a very strong player
makes a losing move in an intricate
position Alaska would catch him nine
times out of ten capablanca says that he
himself would catch you eight times out
of ten if you were a strong player so he
still holds lost her to be the better
player and he says that it would be a
really really tough match the toughest
one of course Capablanca ever faced
yeah yeah that's a little bit of
increase to a reversed knowledge I do
hope you enjoyed that now getting back
to this game it's an interesting game
like I said I don't know if the
gentleman really is named rule opus but
maybe you will have better luck
fingering
figuring it out but okay couple Blanc
opens with E for he has the white pieces
as this is a simultaneous exhibition we
have E 5 sorry about that
and here even though we don't know if a
cappella is playing against a gentleman
named Rudy Lopez he avoids playing the
reuleaux PES against mr r Lopez so he
goes for Bishop to c4 in Bishop's
opening with Bishop to c5 now the boy
variation of the bishops opening and
Knight to c3
we have Knight to f6 d3 backup of Blanca
preparing to develop the dark square
Bishop nice to see six and now push up
to g5 pinning the knight here we have h6
asking kappa blanka do you want to move
back or do you want to capture on f6 now
we have a bushel to h4 and here a couple
uncle mentions d6 is just normal from
black a very very natural but his
opponent mr. Martinez goes for g5 a very
aggressive approach we have Bishop to g3
and now even h5 preparing h4 to trap
Capablanca Bishop here so Capablanca
reacts to this of course he says it's
not really all that of an impressive
move he plays h4 and now he says if
black allows White Knight f3 then white
will win the game so let's say you try
something like you can go night here
then you lose the h5 pawn but you could
try Luke g8 in the sky
you would get something like pawn
captures rook captures and now Knight to
f3
keeping the rook back after the rook
moves not Knight to d5
you get Knight captures pawn captures
and after the night finally moves the e5
pawn would be lost
just that d6 move is really really
missing from blacks setup here
even if Knight captures the knife
captures if Queen e7 check King F 1
white would still have a winning game
here yeah the black king is still in the
center you can go Queen f3 is been
bringing the rock over 2 e 1 you can go
rook h44
just so many possibilities for white and
not none there there are all that
impressive for black so after h4 a
couple up his opponent as I already
mentioned seems to be a fairly strong
player plays g4 of course does not allow
Knight to f3 we have Queen to d2 by
Capablanca preparing queenside castle
and now d6 we have Knight G to E - Queen
to e7 developing the Queen preparing to
develop the LightSquared bishop and also
black ones the Castle queenside and here
kappa blanka castles King side actually
so it seems that we will maybe have a
game of opposite side castles and here
we have a 6 and here is a very
interesting moment where kappa blanka
says a6 is a waste of time
even though the engine would an engine
would say that this is the best move for
black in the position but that's what I
mentioned a few days ago I don't know if
you've seen my video where Lacko played
against Caruana Caruana played a6 and
well it's a popular line today of the
Queens gambit declined but III mentioned
like a hundred years ago you know people
would say a six what a waste of time
such is the case here couple monka says
it's a waste of time but the engine
approves of the move I mean just one of
the ways engines have changed the game
capablanca says instead of a a6 maybe up
to d7 would have been better for black
just you know going for castles without
wasting time but ok with Knight to d5
back up a banca Knight captures he
captures on d5 and now Knight to d4 with
Knight captures Bishop captures now c3
taking the darks who
back Bishop to b6 ending out d4 this is
what Capablanca meant why wasting time
with a six now if the bishop was in d7
maybe you could immediately Castle
queenside but here you're still don't
have that option
you cannot capture or something like
that you can open the e-file row could
win the Queen so here instead of going
something like e 4 which wouldn't be all
that great you could go something like
rook F e1 and if F 5 defending and then
just better left for preparing Bishop to
g5 and it would be a lot of problems for
black of course you cannot capture here
because mushroom g5 wins the Queen now
the Queen is trapped so here one of the
few moments where black is actually okay
to play f6 and here we do have f6 for
Martinez
and here rook 81 by capablanca we have
Bishop to d7 and now Bishop to f4
capablanca takes this opportunity that
the pawn is well it's pinned you cannot
capture as you would lose the Queen 3
maneuver the bishop over to e3 but
capablanca felt it necessary to to
explain that this doesn't work I mean
you can grab black's queen but you just
lose too much material for example pawn
captures now you can capture capture and
capture and after Queen captures now you
do when the Queen will rock you one but
you just lose so much material King b8
now you can go Queen e5 attack the rook
and the pawn and after okay faith you
can win the pawn but then your f2 phone
is just too weak remember should capture
skin of one and now you will lose this
pawn and well let's say b5 but should be
three
captures with check King e2 now Bishop
goes back and the white really has no
and no material to continue playing this
game once black figures out hard to
develop this rook let's say like this it
will be it will be an easily winning
game for black but for some reason and I
I don't think it was necessary to Blanca
felt it was necessary to show this line
but okay Bishop to f4 we have castles
finally a clean side castle by black
Bishop to e3 and now comes Luke dt8 just
occupying the e-file we have g3 by Kappa
blonde
not allowing any further pawn pushes on
the on the King side and now King to be
8 we have B 4 by kappa blanka preparing
a for white now
once the bust open the Queen side as we
do have castles of opposite cut of
opposite sides and here
f5 seems like an interesting move
preparing f4 but again this Bishop to g5
is just very annoying for black after
Queen g7 you can get captures captures
and now let's say d6 white white could
pose a lot of problems for black here
but it does seem to be playable but okay
after before we have Bishop to a 4 this
is how Martinez prevents capablanca from
expanding on the Queen side now the
bishop is just in the way and you're not
getting rid of it that easily kappa
blanka plays Bishop to b3 tries to
eliminate it this way we have Queen to
d7 now if mr. capture screen captures D
capture son e5 and now we have Bishop
captures I mean III and I said
sufficient Zhuge and now you could
capture with the roof but then black
could just trade off a trade off a lot
of material so couple Blanca decides to
capture with D F pawn we have F captures
on e3 now pressuring the f6 pawn so F
captures on e5 and now Capablanca goes
for roof to f6 prepares for doubling
rooks on the F file and Kabbalah Blanca
says that maybe this wasn't the best
idea maybe maybe a c4 or just you know
improving the position as a couple Anka
says that it will be too easy for black
to equalize here which is a possibility
Bishop captures on b3 was played here 8a
captors on b3 and now kappa blanka says
if rook H to f8 then white it would be
very hard for white to hope for
something but his opponent for some
reason plays rook to e7 and continues on
doubling rooks on the e-file now why
would you want to double rooks on the
e-file it's well it's hard to answer
that question I think here we have a
moment where Martinez actually knew that
group h2 f8 was the best move but he
thought I'm playing against cup of Lanka
I don't want to play too good of a move
I'm just
play rookie seven played the other rook
to e8 barricade myself here and
Capablanca will not be able to you know
do anything maybe that was the case here
it's hard to say but here a couple
Blanca does take this opportunity to
double our crooks on the F file and now
we have rook H to e8 and now black has
doubled rooks on the e-file for some
reason maybe maybe the idea was he for
and rookie five or something but
capablanca blocks it would be for first
now we have Queen to b5 and now rook to
a-1 now if c4 comes with an attack on
the Queen b5 is next and the white is
definitely breaking through so here
Martinez just returns with the Queen
Queen to d7 and now just c4 so here
because this rook H to f8 move was not
played acaba Blanca just received this
huge boost of initiative now Martinez
goes for four rook to f7 and now he
wants to occupy the F file and exchange
works kappa blanka well i just we have
rook captures Queen captures and now
comes Luke to f1 with an attack against
Martinez Queen we have Queen to g7 and
now rook to f5 pressuring the h5 pawn
and here we have rook to f8 here if you
if you capture the pawn let's say rook
captures you get rook to f3 not not any
not activity you want to allow black so
here after Luke to f8 Capablanca played
an excellent move it's we could say it's
it's a winning move so feel free to
pause the video here and figure out the
move Capablanca played he did not
capture the h-bond I'll give you a
couple of seconds as usual for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations you have just defeated
Mr Lopez and for those you who just
won't enjoy the show
Queen to g5 this is this is the
wonderful idea now of course if you
capture the Queen rook captures with
check and then after we move the king
white captures the Queen white is upper
rook and if you don't capture the Queen
let's say we capture the rook then white
wins the Queen not good not good at all
so after this Queen g5 move by kappa
blanka we have Queen to h8
but now couple of languages grabs the
point we have Queen captures on h5 Queen
captures rook captures and now rook to
f3 black is able to infiltrate but it is
far too late
the g3 point and b3 pawn around her
attacks first cup of Lanka defends it
we have rook after son b3 and now comes
Luke to f5 and it was in this position
that our Lopez Martinez resigned the
game on move 38 what if you resign well
there is no way ever you can stop this H
point from Queen whatever you try you
can try roof captures here but then just
the pawn continues if you don't if you
try checking the black King just look if
to completely completely sufficient
black will not be able to trade as well
you can see that after h5 the King is
nowhere near the square of the pawn so
the of course the the King will not be
able to reach the point in time and well
there are no other moves that are that
are even remotely considerable sir after
this rook to f5 Martinez resigned and a
very nice victory for capablanca and s
couple on conventions this after a cap
for some b3 just rook H to f8 and it's
it's very hard for for for white to go
for anything look e to f1 but now you
can just trade reposition the Queen
maybe even trade the other rooks and and
you will have a fine position you can go
Queen h7 you know even if Y doubles up
here you will always be able to harass
the white king as what this pawn really
prevents white the white King from
escaping all that much so it was a very
impressive game from mr. Martinez mr r
Lopez Martinez who might be rural opus
Martinez we well for now at least we
don't know but yeah it was at this
moment that he started messing up just
decided to double up on the e-file and
allow kappa blanka this beautiful
initiative that just well ended in this
it ended when Queen to g5 was played as
I mean most of you were able to find it
how about there after work a5 does the
end so yeah that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it some of you have been
asking me in the comments were
are we going now with the widow cup
Blanca saga I don't know I thought maybe
cover a few more games from this
simultaneous exhibition then maybe cover
a few games from some other isolated
incidents and then most likely the next
the next big event will be the 1918
tournament played in New York where
kappa blanka played his famous game
against Frank James Marshall were
Marshall first unleashed the Marshall
attack but we already covered that game
so I will not be doing a video on that
game again but I will when we're
preparing for that tournament I will
invite you for those who haven't seen it
to check it out or you can just check it
out up front maybe if you're if you're
if you just can't wait but yeah that's
basically the plan and then we're gonna
see you know we're very close to a cup
of Wonka's match with Lasker yeah once
again this is the game I do hope you
enjoyed it and a lot of you have been
asking me for a game for an eventual
game as it was Chucky's 50th birthday
but I already covered what I consider to
be you want to his best game what I
consider to be von Schuch immortal his
great victory over Kasparov in Linares
1991 so if you haven't seen it do check
it out it's a really impressive game by
von Schuch first link you will see in
the description below I will take you to
this wonderful game so do check it out I
would like to thank Raymond young they
understand which Sylvain - na goo ami
Albert and undressed Martin for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos
Sarah thank all for watching and I will
see you soon most likely continuing the
capablanca saga but also checking up on
your suggestions as usual thank you all
and I'll see you soon have an excellent
rest of your day